ever thought I want to invest in stocks
but it feels a lot like going to Las
Vegas well you're not alone but what if
I told you it's actually the opposite
imagine we tracked the value of a
grocery cart filled with one share from
each of 500 largest U.S companies stock
that's essentially the S P 500 index
over the last 90 years you can see a
clear upward pattern despite the many
dramatic downturns so in reality the
longer you remain invested the more
likely it is you'll turn a profit
whereas with casinos all games are
designed to give the house a
mathematical Edge they don't leave their
profits to chance that's why when
someone wins a lot they can end up
getting kicked out for cheating they
know that the longer you play the worse
your odds become see very different want
more help understanding how the stock
market really works check us out at two
cents on YouTube
[Music]